no texts or emails from your boss after
hours meeting free fridays and an app
that kicks you out of chats some
companies and governments such as spain
portugal and france want employees to
unplug from work
i don't feel bad or i don't have the
urge of responding if i'm enjoying my
social life if i'm with my family or
friends the pandemic thrusts the issue
of disconnecting from work under a new
light as millions across the globe began
working from home in one poll conducted
by software company buffer nearly one
third of respondents said unplugging
from their duties after hours was the
hardest adjustment one implication is
clear from ongoing research people need
time to disconnect amid a wave of
resignations in the u.s with as many as
4.4 million people leaving jobs in
september companies are looking for
solutions in order to retain their
workers goldman sachs said it would
enforce limits on working hours after
some employees complained they were
working 95 hours per week while this san
francisco startup is testing digital
tools to make workers disconnect we'd
rather solve those problems and
understand them and the only way that we
see to do that is to start experimenting
to find out what these business policies
do for company productivity and employee
retention we look to europe where
legislation to give workers the right to
disconnect has been implemented in
several countries i think the employees
are more active more proactive and more
productive
although technology helped employees
stay connected during the pandemic for
many it also blurred the lines between
work life and home life if you have work
on your mind you can't really be present
in both places at the same time that's
leo belkin a professor at lehigh
university who has researched the impact
of receiving emails from work out of
hours on employee well-being it not only
hurts the non-work life but it also
might
impede your productivity as well because
you're not really thinking about work
either you're not fully present for work
but companies that tell workers to
disconnect face a number of risks
belkin's research argues that
disconnection policies are not
implemented correctly they could
actually end up having negative effects
on mental health yes workers have to
have a right to disconnect however there
are certain jobs
that
prohibiting people to check email
actually might increase anxiety right
because you would be thinking what's
going on what if there is an emergency
or something else is happening
in europe where portugal's parliament
recently announced labor laws to give
workers the right not to be contacted
after hours companies have had mixed
reactions while some have complained
that such rules can hurt flexibility
others have embraced them
this is the spanish branch of global
insurer axa which introduced
disconnection policies in the collective
bargaining agreement as the right to
disconnect became law in france and
spain in 2017 and 2018.
the spanish law calls on employers to
set up internal policies that define how
employees exercise their right to
disconnect
but how does that work in practice we
had room for improvement
so that's why we took the decision to
promote it even more to to improve some
behaviors to improve some habits that
are present in the spanish culture maybe
in the past we tend to have meetings
later in the evening
we visited nuria an employee who is
mostly working from home
her job is to provide training to
managers and workers and she is required
by company policy to finish her meetings
by 6 pm
at the end of her working day nuria uses
an app to log how many hours she's
worked
so so whenever i finish my working day
what i usually do is
get in my phone and log into an app
called tempo mobile press the salida
which is
exit and i just go out to enjoy my my
day after that she says she uses her
time to catch up with friends like her
colleague alberto
according to the company's internal
surveys employee loyalty and
satisfaction at axa has improved
significantly digital disconnections
produce
more efficiency productivity
and good relationships it's hard to
determine exactly how these policies
have influenced business performance
overall axa's parrot company had a
challenging year in 2020 with shrinking
sales during the pandemic
legislation that requires companies to
refrain from contacting employees after
hours has not been enacted in the u.s
in the united states the culture is so
much work oriented i think it would be
very tough battle to pass any loss in
the united states like that
state lawmakers in new york city
proposed a right to disconnect bill in
2018 however it was opposed strongly by
business leaders during a public hearing
in 2019. we do not support the right to
disconnect bill due to concerns that
this would negatively impact our member
businesses particularly those that are
small businesses unwise to use new york
city as a testing ground for such a
novel approach
some u.s businesses have considered
introducing their own rules to help
workers to unplug loom a tech startup
developing a video communication
platform has more than 170 employees
people are working at women all around
the world its co-founder says to help
employees in different time zones not to
work after hours the startup created a
program that can disconnect people from
group chats in the communication
platform slack it's a really simple
thing it just automates the it automates
the flow of kicking out of channels
there's no hard data yet but looms says
it is evaluating the impact of the
policies which are meant to help detract
and retain talent during a period of
economic growth employees in tech have
more optionality than they've ever had
before keeping your employees happy and
engaged in this hiring market in
technology where people can work
anywhere and from anywhere and workers
in tech are more in demand than ever is
just like good for business
you